thanks uh everyone for uh your attention
um I want to talk today about how
generative AI can help us understand
what layers are saying
um and we're going to be looking at a
few questions that I think are important
when we want to do
um when we want to understand what
they're saying and we're going to be
starting with a very very basic stuff
here in this talk so
um we're not making any assumptions
about what they're what is Meaningful
about whales we're not making
discretizations we try to be as raw as
possible and so one of the questions one
of the main questions would be what is
Meaningful and spermatical communication
system and how we approach that question
in a system that is as unknown to us or
as as alien to us as as primary
Communications
we want to understand what rules
specific rules govern their
Communication System right that's going
to be one of the goals
um what how you know how how things work
when you put the codas together or
clicks together
um in a similar way when when you're um
you know asking ourselves in language
how things work when you put words
together or sounds together
we're going to be talking a little bit
about
um you know a couple of further steps
once we deal with the first two
questions what design features of human
language do sperm whales have
um so that's going to be one thing that
we're going to be interested as well
um in this project and also one thing
that is very exciting and we should not
forget is that that their Communication
System needs to be learned how do they
learn and how how do they learn it and
how do we model that right so the end
goal obviously is to have to understand
what the meaning and what the form is
right so the pairing between meaning and
form is going to be the end goal but I
think these are a few questions I was
thinking about like what what am I doing
in this project these are the few
questions that I think I'm asking myself
um and the work that we do
so um we talked about black boxes today
already right and one of the things that
is super super um kind of one of the
Frontiers currently in AI research is
interpretability of those black boxes
like how can we understand them and
um one of the important thing is to
understand these spermware communication
system so to use a to leverage AI to
understand spermills for that we will
need interpretability we will need to
understand what these models are
learning because if they're only
performing if they're only translating
we will we will get the meaning maybe
but we will not understand how their
language works so in order to use AI to
decode sperm whales we will need to
understand how AI itself works
um why is AI important why is gender of
AI important is because humans are
biased right we hear things that we're
used to I mean there there's there's
parts of communication systems from us
that we don't even hear right but we can
analyze but we pay attention to things
that are important to us as humans and
we want to have Assist you know we want
to have ai that is less biased that is a
paying that that's paying attention to
stuff that are non-humans in order to
kind of understand what it what is
Meaningful in in this in this case and
so what we're gonna in the first part of
the talk I'm going to show how you can
leverage interpretability techniques to
to kind of to force AI or like deep deep
learning model to give us clues about
what is Meaningful so basically it's not
that they're giving us straightforward
answers using these models interpret
interpreting them to shrink the
hypothesis space so that they kind of
steer us into what might be meaningful
in this communication system
okay so first
for a sec you know for a few slides
let's forget about whales and and talk
about language human language is great
we all agree um about that why is it
great because
um we know what it is right and we do
not know what real communication is and
so we we can we can play on human
language and then test on Wales
um to to kind of understand what is
Meaningful okay so what do humans do
when when we when we speak when we
communicate for spoken language
we have information in our head right
reform information and we encode that
information into spoke in into waves
right
um and and then somebody hears those
waves uh okay so so the listener hears
those waves and decodes information okay
so it's encoding and decoding right and
we understand extremely well how human
language works right we've been studying
it for like thousands of years finally
lived hundreds of years before you know
BCE and and and we understand it really
well so
um so so the ground truth exists right
and we know that the word like pit is
you know
um is means something other than spit
um because we've added the sound there
we know that word that like pit means
something else than bid because we we
changed one sound from one word to the
other we know that sounds change meaning
the sounds are called phone exchange
meaning uh we know that there are more
themes we know exactly how their work
cross-linguistically we know how to
create you know create words out of
morphemes you know how to create senses
out of morphemes and so that's all great
and we we have acquisition data and so
on
so another reason why
um language is a great testing ground as
well is because
um speech especially spoken language has
a wide variety of different more or less
complex processes
um and the charm scan hierarchy some
speech processes are very simple some
speech processes are very complex and we
can test them we know what humans can
learn and you know humans are pretty
intelligent so
um so we have like an upper bound the
lower bound of what is learnable in
humans in in spoken language
um so so so we're going to be using this
as a as a testing ground right
um
for so language as a testing ground for
later on when we switch to Wales the
models that I'm using for modeling
language learning are against Gans are
amazing for all sorts of things
um I love Gans
um but but if you think of um so we've
seen a lot of Transformers and
Transformers are great for performance
but if we want to build models that
learn more like humans I think we need
to switch to cans why
because they learn by imitation and kind
of imagination and and and not
necessarily in that next sequence
prediction and that is great because
they're extremely creative
um it is the only deep learning
architecture fires I know where the
model the the the net the architecture
that does that generates data never
actually sees the data
okay and that is huge right so the way
the training in Gans work is you have a
generator that produces data that
generates and you have the discriminator
that has to distinguish what is real and
what is fake so the generator is trained
on tricking another Network into
thinking that it's producing real data
like in other architectures like art
encoders it never accesses data directly
that means that there are no direct
connection and it's not replicating it's
innovating and that is crucial and for
for that precise purpose Gans need to be
quite
um sophisticated in how they learn their
internal representations
and we'll see over and over again we're
showing that on speech they're they're
learning disentangled symbolic like
rule-like representations on on highly
complex processes where which with you
know would fall on the more complex
um aspect of the charm scan hierarchy
um and so so they're extremely creative
they create new words we'll see and they
represent what we know is Meaningful in
language with disentangle discrete
representation the only thing we need is
a technique to access those
representations and we have that so
that's good
uh so this is you know this is uh uh how
they learn so the generator
um needs to produce data needs to
produce speech right
um from random noise distribution right
so it takes some random
um Z latent space which is uniformly
distributed variables from minus one to
one and it takes a few codes okay
um it uses those small tiny Vector
basically tiny compared to other
architecture this is like a total
dimensionality of this is 100. so one it
takes 100 numbers
and turn them into speech spoken
language
um that this you know this generated
stuff gets sent to discriminator that
needs to evaluate what is related what
is fake right and however in time at the
beginning the generator is super bad
it's producing noise because what else
would it do and the discriminator is
great because it's it's so easy to put
you know distinguish in ways from speech
but in training the generator becomes
really really good so that the
discriminator doesn't know what is
written what is fake anymore so and this
this model had to basically build the
internal representation such that it'll
output meaningful speed it's a speech
um in a very efficient way okay so
that's the class again relationship this
is adversarial training okay so what we
add for linguistic modeling is this
another another Network
um which need which needs to communicate
with the generator okay so what needs to
happen here is the generator takes some
code which we consider to be information
that's for for a second consider this to
be information
encode it into sound
and then this guy needs to look at the
sound
and figure out what unique information
did this generator have
when it was producing this particular
sound
okay so what needs to happen is encoding
needs to happen and decoding needs to
happen everything else we leave to up to
the ends okay but but the idea is this
this model needs to look at output and
say okay this unique code you had this
unique code when you were producing it
yeah and it just explains again so you
have basically two different inputs one
is random vectors another one is the
code yes the generator uses yes it's
kind of just you stack them together and
send it what's the overlap in the
information between the the two parts of
the people none
I mean they're they're both randomly
sampled but this one this one has either
one hot or a binary code sampling this
is a uniform for minus one to one they
do contain similar information because
your two networks are able to
to do some discrimination so this one
the this one estimates only the code it
doesn't care about this but yeah there
might be um there might be mutual
information but what when when we are
actually testing there's little in
during learning so this random space
encodes other things than
um then the code the code space
yeah that's a good question what happens
is the code is an
analogous to words and then individual
bits
are analogous to sub lexical structure
like phoneme so
um the network is able to kind of you
know
learn that their words and that are also
sub words like you know the words have S
in common or words have to be in common
and encode both of these things with
this kind of bit encoding and also
holistic encoding so C1 couldn't be for
example something like that and it is in
many cases it is yep
that's the same but for different codes
so the information is different but the
audio format that comes out of the
generator is the same well so these guys
need to be efficient in their
communication and you're you're pointing
to a really good point is the net the
network could learn to encode anything
about speech using these codes right it
could encode gender it's getting called
speaker identity that would be
informative it could encode length of
other answers that will also be pretty
informative right but the most
informative thing
is to pair each code with unique words
which is great and that happens over and
over and over again so whenever you feed
it speech it doesn't care as much about
a speaker identity doesn't care about
how high your pitch is whatever it cares
about words
um now we're going to be seeing that
it's more complicated than than you know
when you're looking at training range
distributions you're not seeing a lot
because these models are highly complex
well we found a trick to really access
what they learn is by taking these codes
and setting them to extreme values like
15 0 0 instead of one zero zero and
that's where you're basically getting
categoricity and disentanglement really
tangibly
I had a quick question so if you're
using the word phony here how do you
distinguish phoneme from morphine
because morphemes are meaning the
smallest meaningful units does that make
a difference here
um well so what we're observing that
they're encoding sublexico structure we
haven't really got into uh they can do
both they can encode phonemes morphemes
and phonemes
um but but but well so there's a
separate standard as an independent
study that was really interesting just
came out on our hype they use these
models to to train
um on to train on English and French
nasalization whereas in English
organization naturalization is not
contrastive so just like extra
information whether in French it's
really you have to know whether it
empowers nasalized or not and the model
learned these two things differently so
you can distinguish from you know
allophonic sound from really contrastive
sounds uh but but yeah morphemes the can
handle but it is unclear whether it
makes really distinct really Salient
distinction between more payments
problems we're looking into that and
then there are people that believe that
phonemes don't exist at all right yeah
yeah so uh so like sub maximum Universe
have like certain probability
distribution over that much so if you're
giving it like a uniform code
distribution but this pushes it towards
certain things or not or like it's
actually quite interesting that's a
great question um so so let's say it it
cares about the proportion of data and
and you know if you have like a bit
string of five bits as you would say
three bits to encode something that is
as proportion so three uh three divided
by five to the power you know five to
the power of five
um no so five to the power of two to the
power of Pi
um roughly the same proportion would be
of that lexical structure in the
training data so it's using all sorts of
of dependencies like that which is not
because humans are pretty good at this
kind of frequency matching as well
yeah
but last thing for me so do I understand
correctly that the blue part you'll
never really see the training data right
so have it not been for the orange part
it could make up completely arbitrary
sounds
sorry so the blue part you'll never see
the training day right so the generator
produces arbitrary arbitrary thing so it
can make up the codes and the sounds but
the the orange part it was makes it
produce uh yeah exactly yeah that's
that's that's that's great yes so that's
that's what we used for um for for
training games why is this cool because
we know that we have to perceive and
produce sounds to learn language right
production perception Loop is a
necessary condition for our learning and
and remember so we we we encode
information when we decoded and we also
here are what we what we've said there's
a feedback loop directly from our mouth
to our ear and so um this is this is a a
better representation of human learning
because we have the production aspect we
have the perception aspect it's from raw
acoustic data it's just raw waveforms we
are not
um assuming any discretization but
discretization emerges automatically
it's fully unsupervised and we've even
shown that humans and kids have similar
developments the stages when they're
learning rules over their learning
phonology for example tone three with
tone three in Mandarin is difficult to
learn for human kids and also for these
these models which is a nice so over
over again we're seeing that acquisition
as well has a similar trajectories in
these two
models okay so so I mentioned that we're
gonna have to do interpretability
um in order to use AI generative eye for
understanding experiments we need to
understand what the AI is doing and for
that speech is great as well why because
vision is very more complex most of the
work you know is on vision and vision is
super complex you have like millions of
objects and millions of colors and you
know you can have pictures of galaxies
and pictures of armchairs or avocado
chairs
um
but but speech is quite simple it has
only a few sounds
um it's one You Know spoken language is
one dimensional which is also nice if
you do a interpretability work because
you are adding Dimensions quickly and if
you start with one that's better than if
you start with two because it's easier
to imagine things that are lower
Dimension also
um we can compare Human Performance with
spoken these model AI models but trained
on speech better because
uh these are General it's called
generative AI right and if you think of
what we humans do
on Vision we only absorb Vision we don't
produce Vision we don't have big screens
on our heads that
all right well there's a lot of layers
that that were needed to get there and
yeah you can draw and but but it's much
more indirect that I'm accessing your
your imagination you can imagine things
but like imagine Apple it's very hard to
see for me to see what they exactly
after what kind of apple you're magic
maybe now with decoding Brains it's
going to be easier
um but that's you know with speech we
are constantly producing speech we're
innovating and the humans have innate
generator basically our articulators are
in a generator so so that for that
purpose as well
um
um spoken language is great for
interpretability okay so
um I'm still trying to convince you that
that these models are great models of
spoken and spoken language learning
um a couple of things that that happened
that that are really important kind of
promising gave promising results for
when we transfer this to the rails is
they they learn they're they're very
creative so they can produce new words
um we tested we train the model on an
eight words and it starts producing
novel words of English that it never
heard before right similar
in the wheels no the the models not not
yet Wales
um but it's also producing new codas
that had never heard before and maybe
those are you know similarly possible
coders as these words are possible
English words right so um It produced
like some like start dust carrot and it
also produces sart
is not a word of English right but it
could well be where it's following
phonotactic rules of English so from
very limited data from eight words it's
learning a lot about English from the
tactics and putting things you know
together
um we've also observed over and over
again that symbolic like rule-like
categorical disentangle representations
emerge if you're if you're willing to
play with with latent space a little bit
[Music]
um
language uh what do you mean by symbolic
like yeah
um and then
representation yeah so um so so that's a
really good question
um because it also kind of touches on
what these models are doing and what we
are doing spoken language is the only
continuous physical aspect of language
everything else is this representation
right mental representational units so
to speak but but spoken language is the
only tangible physical continuous space
and so what we are doing is we're going
from sound which is just air pressure by
fluctuations to mental representations
that carry meaning that have information
right
um and and that that's what these models
need to be trained on as well so the
process is similar right so
discretization
um and Rule like and symbolic like why
am I using the like classifier there is
because some people on the symbolic side
would be angry if I just say symbolic
um so just to protect myself but um
but but the the idea is that we're
trying to push
for how much symbolic representations
emerge in models that are purely you
know
um
connection is so where you have no
symbolic representations and and this is
about you know observing you just give
the network stream uh continuous sound
and see okay will it learn symbols
but so start adjusting here it happens
to be the works that are involved like
for which I can produce a mental
representation
but like does this learning model then
think
that like serves as this out of this
object yes that's a great question
actually uh we we believe that it has
um that it has representations to make
it um you know that it knows that sarv
is adding s the dark and But but so the
the idea is that if you have a binary
code right
um each binary code represents the word
this is word one this is word two this
is where you know this is worth three
uh but what happened is these models is
that individual bits
um represent what you know what we think
what is called sublexical structures of
sounds or like chunks of sounds and
that's how we think that the model knows
I mean it has a representation of you
know this is an S added to something
else
which is going to be important when we
do this kind of work on on visuals okay
so we're you're producing a continuous
signal here but we're visualizing these
things back in uh phoning space or
letter space so how
analyze it you can you know just do
phonetic analysis unfortunately I don't
have a recording I usually play this but
it's on YouTube so uh you can listen to
them you're right um
to answer your question in in a better
way we train the network that does not
just produce sound that moves
articulated which then produce sound
through our external physical model that
we're pausing during training and now we
can say well it's moving representations
of um articulators in a similar way as
humans are we have just I like out the
the paper that icaps introduce that and
so that's you know gives you more
confidence saying well that's a problem
but but like here in particular I can
actually imagine a couple of ways of
making start right one of which is that
you don't actually pronounce the final T
and it just shows up as a shortening of
the ah and another one where you
actually you know start with this
inspiration so which is uh
like that's I think it's adding s to a
dark okay yeah but but let's say so so
um I mean as is s is a part of training
data and so is the the articulate the
articulators they don't have a t no SD
sequence is not yeah but but in
articulation again we call our
reputation again the model is producing
even sounds that it never heard before
like coffee or you know stuff like that
so it's really Innovative and even an
even better
it says Coffee in a New York accent so
it's also on YouTube
so a quick question about the definite
rules so it's obviously should depend on
the training set right so it's your
training boards are something like ask
ask yeah
foreign
but but you can force actually stuff
that is outside of training
distributions
um so so the way this work is so the
main technique that allows this kind of
work we'll see later is to just go
generate in the latent space African
training with extreme values of a single
unit
um and that's that's the and then you
know if one unit represents one rule or
one sound and another unit represents a
second ruler and second sound if you
kind of
um let's manipulate them together you're
seeing this
um compositional rule that is happening
in real time
and and maybe next slide will answer a
couple of your questions is so we can
test as complex stuff as as
multiplication with these kind of models
and learning happens you know Learning
Happens
um there despite you know Gary Marcus
saying in 99 well no no neural net can
do
replication right
um and and it can do from raw audio in
in in encodes
um something as as complex as copying
why is copying complex because for if
you have Peru if you copy the first two
sound the copied material will be P if
you have Maru
um uh if you have copy the first The
Sounds the copy part will be ma right so
it's not like simple adding s through
English plurals it's
um looking at what you have in the base
and then reduplicating that and here
I think I actually have
security security
so so I manipulated only one unit in
latent space which is the code that the
network used to learn for duplication
and there's nothing that specifically
saying for me saying you know learn
multiplication it just learns the
replication because that's the most
informative thing to do and as you're
interpolating they're the copied
material just disappears from the output
so that's reassuring
is it possible to back up to your gamut
slide sure
so
is the longer term thing that you're
hoping to do
I'm going to drop sperm whale training
data yes here I'm going to have a
language that gets that I create my Gan
creates
and then they'll know that the language
uses pronounceable things for sperm
whales yes and therefore we could
potentially teach the sperm whales our
new sperm whale language we can't learn
theirs but we know that this is
pronounceable by them and we know what
it means so is that that is that's my
there's description of my next slide
okay so so
um so so so the can we leverage this
approach right it learned a lot of
things about human language learn sounds
learn words and learns complex processes
can we leverage that to understand what
is Meaningful in sperm whales okay so um
sperm rails also have to do this right
um probably right so they have some
information
um they decode it into their codas or
clicks and they have to decode it right
so this is how we're treating this this
um problem
and so that's precisely what we're doing
right we are training again that learn a
lot of stuff about language on Wales and
then probing it what did you learn right
so it's an answer fully unsupervised
model you could learn anything it could
learn anything about audio Communication
System it's not limited to a way as to
human vocal track at all
and and so so we're training it on codas
right so the generator needs to learn to
imitate codas
this is this aspect right this
relationship forces the generator to
produce whalish instead of human
language
and then these two guys need to exchange
information right
um you get some code
it needs to encode that information into
codas now it's going to be a lot of
confusion because code encoder are
similar things
and this one needs to
figure out okay what did you encode in
this particular coda
sorry the original code you start with
in the whole is this the binary code in
the beginning of time is is just a
binary code
nothing it picks up what it is
right it's the relationship with school
I mean this is kind of similar to a
previous talk right but it's just like
this
is
yeah
do you think what it does it's generic
separation between the two parts like
between the code and the rest because
that's the most efficient way there's a
lot of speed back propaganda so if the
human can guess what GG used is it
called to get spinalized so G must be
consistent right so what happens is
separation resistance
so the gold stands up it's whatever but
over time whenever the signal appears
instantly it's the code the same thing
otherwise there's there so so I'm not
asking how I'm asking more so you know
so you you throw you you throw the in
speech right you give Network eight a
couple of words and you throw in a
couple of codes now you could learn
anything right because those it hears
many speakers and it's hears many
instances of words
okay so the meaning of the code in
speech is
on the entire binary code level is words
right I can show that because I can show
that extremely well because if I go
after training and I set this one to
1500 it'll always give me a single word
okay and as I mentioned the bid level
it's sublexical structure because word
like suit and sarc are similar right so
why are we doing this on Windows because
we want to have the same system that
learns so well speech
so learn whatever is there meaningful
whatever is informative now that doesn't
mean that that's actually informative so
the natural thing is to compare what you
get out of this with things but which
encoders yes okay well we'll see
well so so the thing is we are we're
we're trying to you know that's the
point we're trying to you know learn
something informative that doesn't mean
it'll learn what is actually informative
in this but it's a good candidate it's
it's a pretty good candidate
um so we we train them to imitate web
communication and learn something
informative and then we need to
introspect what did you learn okay so
first the model can learn covers and
generate code so that's good you know it
generates tablet like site code it
hopefully Wales would recognizes you
know one of the wrong the thing on the
left doesn't
we have uh some Brazil you know
so you're bothered by this yeah
it's Innovative Innovative it's Sri
Lankan no the the long pause at the
front oh is it oh it doesn't know that
but codas like that do exist somewhere
oh okay well that's the thing that we're
observing over and over again it's it's
you know just like start is not a word
of English but it could be it's
innovating it's creating new coders that
are now outside of training distribution
but many of them are you know I didn't
know it's true this particular is Sri
Lankan but um but it's it's in a way I
mean it's probably over generating to
some degree but um it's it's really cool
that we're getting Innovative data but
that's interesting like do you see on
the language data you see phonemes that
are tested in languages other than the
language that you're training on
um in in the articulate where you're
constrainable articulation yeah yeah
um okay so so this is the the main the
main thing where we're where we're where
we're trying to figure out what is what
did it learn
and so as I mentioned during training
the latent space is within minus one and
one okay so it's middle within minus one
month and if you sample these
and these variables like this
these variables have a lot of complex
interaction between them they're very
complicated okay and so you're not
you're basically not seeing anything
you're not seeing any effect so what
this what what makes this work possible
is that you we're taking single units
here and stretching them way outside of
training range which means that a single
unit overrides all over level
interactions that are there and tell you
this is what I learned okay so to
shafi's question
uh so we we add causal inference method
borrowed from causal inference to to
test what did what bits represent in in
rails right so this is right where we're
stretching single bit variables instead
of zero and zero zero fifteen zero and
we're actually interpolating and
observing causal effect that it has on
the data so let's learn
so what we've observed there are two
things that are reassuring that that um
come out of this one says
we observed that number of clicks one
bit encodes number of clicks which is
great because that's probably pretty
informative I think that's what you know
people parted it's important
um and you see one bit is getting
disentangled
um
um this is average number of clicks so
bit one gets disentangled there
um as as you're increasing
um values here timing between clicks is
also very important which is great
because
um that's what it's useful uh that's
what humans hypothesize we also observe
that things that are not necessarily
hypothesized by humans which is spectral
mean and just as we were writing this
paper there's other paper came out on
citation articulation that suggests that
they're they're controlling their
articulations more than we thought so
it's actually not out of the question
that spectral you know the actual
spectral properties are meaningful one
thing we also observe so these are do
these two graphs
um regularity or standard deviation of
the spectral means is important so in
other words like you know am I am
keeping the the center of gravity
constant through the clicks or am I very
varying it
um so like starting higher and then
going and so on so I think that's really
promising to look into and I think it
suggests we shouldn't be throwing
Acoustics away it might be important
informations here
um stored in in the acoustic signal
um what we also observe in terms of
rules is that
um
that the model learned on limited data
that the more code as you are the more
clicks you have in a coda the more
regular the enter click timing will be
and it applies that rule on novel and
observed data right it's innovating but
within rules so the rule is it picks up
on on that rule and is able to extend it
to novel unobserved generated data which
is good and so what what what this yeah
over Generations that are bounded and
ones that are not valid
um
that's a tough because for for language
that it's easy for for waves it's
difficult
um
but but it
it doesn't really matter for the
question of like what is Meaningful
why not
because I decide what aspects of these
calls there are actually intentionally
agree no we're only we're looking at
only into what individual bits are
encoding
so yeah the majority
still like really selected the ranges
to obviously see modification so the
majority of the student recognize the
right so to get a language of the exact
quality of stimulation it's not this
majority uh
so that's why we kind of didn't want to
emphasize the size of the effect just in
discovering of is it or not
Dakota
the standard deviation
increasing recent value this is going to
always increase the scientific
Ally so this is representing only one of
the bits so for all other bits this
relationship doesn't know right
and how do I do it and then the next
step so that is how to discover that uh
the relationship exists with regulatives
and how do you argue that if the number
of things that we are disconnected
okay so so one of the ways
generated by AI okay is is can be useful
is it gives like combining
interpretability techniques with these
models unsupervised you know raw raw
speech models give us a way to test what
else is Meaningful we just focused on
four things you can you know discover
anything that you want and if you can
test anything you want you can think of
possibly
um another thing we can test with this
is compositionality we're we're looking
into you know do do do is there any
other interaction between individual
bits which was would tell us there's
more compositionality in the code
structure or not but we haven't been
able to see a lot of compositionality
yet so that's
um that's still still interesting and
and um and and you know we need to look
into this acquisition stages right
um I think one of the main most
important thing in in this project is to
understand how this is learned and how
the acquisition stages work right we in
humans we know exactly what is more
difficult to learn what is easier and
all human kids pretty much I mean many
of them undergo very similar steps and
that gives us a lot of Clues I'm going
to talk a little bit about that later
um and there are other other things that
we I think should try and and are
looking to try and you know Transformers
for modeling longer sequences
interpretability of Transformers audio
Transformers and stuff like that but I
think it's important to
um look at the audio and and see like
these models are telling us or
suggesting us it's not a definite answer
but they're suggesting that uh that the
audio carries information and that's
might be you know key because currently
we have only 22 code of coded types
right if coilers can't be words if this
is a complex
um communication system because it's you
know not enough uh types so so audio
might be the key there to to to getting
to to the um complexity okay for the so
this was the first question right what
is Meaningful and what the rules are
there that we need to
um answer and I think there's a lot more
that we can leverage AI Plus
interpretability
to get to get more more data more
information more results
so um what I wanted to just like briefly
reflect on now this is more like a
reflection from now on out of two this
kind of too high level question what
kind of design features do whales have
what kind of features of of our human
language do whales have and and again
um not something that have a lot of
results on but we're getting there like
we need to get the acquisition
um and and how this is learned
okay so um we know what language is
which I said at the beginning that's
awesome we also understand it really
well I mean language has a lot of really
cool properties right we can lie we can
talk about language itself right we can
um this you know we can be linguist we
can use language to analyze language
itself which is meta language which is
nice we are very productive we can talk
about things yes that happened yesterday
we can talk about things that happen on
imaginary in imaginary worlds
um we can we can uh well everything in
language has structure more or less
compositional structure and stuff like
that right so those are all the cool
things about language and what we want
to do is the where we want to use AI as
well is we want to test it like what
um what what whales have right and I
mean we're not gonna end that discussion
here or even start it well we're going
to be you know going over and over
through all these properties and see
what do whales have what do they do they
don't have
um but where where can AI be useful
um is is basically try to a generative
AI can tell us what is possible in
non-human communication right so it can
tell us okay these are the things that
can emerge even if you're not a human
right yeah it's going to be on us to
kind of go there and test what whales
have but but is um especially
Transformers really are pushing the
boundaries of what what is there that is
possible Right what properties of
language
um um Can emerge in artificial neural
networks and then maybe those same
properties can also emerge in animals if
they're really smart and we think that
experimenters are really smart right
um so I think that there is a crucial
case to be made that we need to study
animals human language and generative AI
right machine learning together right
because we can learn learn from each
other and the questions are actually
very similar that we're asking in this
this specific subfields right there's a
common question
in animal research that says is animal
mind capable of human language it's just
they're you know we are smarter right
with increased power do animals have
everything that we have
which enable human language or is there
something uniquely human some operations
some you know what Chomsky would say
either merge or some you know genetic uh
thing that that happened there that
enables language I mean that's the only
question I'm not giving any answers but
the the reason why generative AI which
is part of the title is important here
is because it tells us what you know we
ask a similar question there as well
which is do current architecture that
we're seeing that that show a lot of
these emerging properties
are there just not powerful enough and
if you increase power they'll become
humans there's going to be there's going
to be AGI or is there something extra
added right there there's need do they
need some extra human stuff human
property or some extra tweaking
architecture that will enable human
level performance or not and so those
those are the questions in parallel
right and and and and one of the you
know case studies that I I just um we
just put on our archive it's like we can
go um you know through design properties
of language and see okay what what is
possible in current generative AI what
can emerge right and one of the Holy
Grails of of linguistics is recursion
right if you look at all the design
features of language and go and look and
go go in animals you'll find most of
them in animals either in linguistically
trained animals where you train animals
on speech or whatever or an alarm a call
animal communication in the wild like
you know there's productivity there's uh
probably compositionality I mean there's
like monkeys that have suffixes and
stuff like that most of most of the
design features are present in animals
not not at the same time not in the same
way as language but the principle is
there except one one big big kind of
disputed uh property which is recursion
is one of the few properties that is not
fun or in language uh in in in animals
and what is recursion is embedding of
phrases within phrases of the same type
right you can always make it's kind of
it link recursion is the Infinity of
language right so
how do you know
well based on my research and my uh my
we don't know well maybe
well not some of their people that have
looked into this it's disputed maybe if
they have a case of recursion in animals
oh I have a question
so I have been well in your previous
slide so you say that that basically the
two questions are do uh animal capable
of human language and our machine
capable of human level performance I
think
it's wrong to uh the the very
formulation of the questions in my
opinion is wrong because you can define
Language
basically without relating it to human
you can Define artificial intelligence
without human human is just one example
but we we still think that there's
something unique about human language
right that we're chasing there are
artificial languages that are as
expressive problem as a human language
and yes yes yes for sure but but I mean
we put value in humans
and we want I mean I'm a cognitive
modeler I want to understand how it's
reasonable to expect it anymore so yeah
no you're right you're right I I agree
with that but um I mean
there is if not if nothing else for
evolutionary purposes right because yes
there are other you know there are other
languages that are other intelligences
but from an evolutionary perspective our
last common ancestor is proper numbers
and chimpanzees so no it's a
we stem from the same common ancestor
right six million years ago probably
um and they do not have language the way
we have and we have that's a significant
question right and so how did that
evolve is it just like increased power
right you're just adding parameters or
is there's something else I mean there's
little biological evidence that there's
something else but maybe there is and
we're not we haven't figured it out yet
and because because the question is like
you know you can get into this higher
level questions like can can can
human-like properties emerge in in large
models and if you think that
intelligence human-like intelligence
emerge from chimpanzees to us
um with no extra tweaks then you could
also think that maybe human-like
intelligence will emerge as you're
increasing the size of these models it
could be not human life could be yes
that is equally capable it's just very
different I agree yeah up I just had a
quick comment about recursion it's a
tough one if we can't decode other
animals to know if they show regards yes
but two Savage has shown some lovely
work and I actually have a video of it
not with me but I could bring it um
where she the the bonobos
um have spontaneous have learned
spontaneously without explicit training
to comprehend human speech she worked
with symbols but they started one of
them particularly started picking up
human speech and she shows very nicely
that when she's masked and she's not
queuing with other visual signs that
they can comprehend recursive types of
commands like go get the there's a ball
right in front of the animal you'll get
the ball that's outside and bring it in
so that's interesting when you see when
you give them codes how they I agree I
agree I mean I mean but they didn't
perform on this uh added level like I
did they perform at level one yeah which
is you know embedding with N1 they
didn't and perform at the betting it and
even if they they perform on embedding
and one there might be people who say
well you know there's just a semantic
soup they're like they're not really
there's not realization I don't agree
with that but you know they have
somewhat valid counter argument but I I
agree I can't see is a great case uh the
history of animals
so for for me one of the things when I
try to think about like whale speech and
and trying not to create this hierarchy
yeah is is this like minimum viable
communication prod product right when
we're talking about masking and how what
can we take out of human language how do
we lose the purpose
um and so do you think recursion may be
an outlier in human language because
human language has
so much embellishment like I gotta
probably ask that question a lot shorter
um so that's a really I mean there's a
really complex and recursion isn't it's
a thing about recurring really complex
because you know the process how when do
when does our processing stop right we
cannot happen like you can always make a
bigger sense right that's why I say
recursion is the Infinity of language
right so you can say Mary said that John
said that for yourself language always
say you know Shane said that Mary said
the Johnson but at some point just
stopped processing stuff right
um also these are not very natural and
and I mean we try to avoid several
layers of recursion
um but but it seems to be kind of the
you know the design feature I mean it
seems to be and it's it's not just an
incentive but but there's a principle
where you can take one phrase and and
and embed it like putting inside a
bigger phrase in a hierarchical
structure and that seems to be you know
a pretty well baked in property of
language and I think you're absolutely
right if you don't know anything about
language animal Communications it'll be
very difficult to evaluate whether it
has recursion or not right but I think
we're I think would be great to
um pay attention to to that in Wales as
as we're learning more about it you know
seeing if they can have you know smaller
phrases in the higher in the larger
phrases if they can do this kind of
embedding I think they'll be highly
consequential and then incidentally uh
the the reason why we're interested in
you know why this is also part of how
generative AI can help in in settling
these questions is we've we've recently
tested whether
um gpt4 has you know explicit recursion
and it's performing really well that's
the first model that's performing really
well on recursion in many respects um
and you can identify it and then add
layers in in what seems to be infinite
um number of layers and and this is this
is um you know an archive since
yesterday
um and and so so but but this is just an
illustration basically of how we can
basically test okay the bond what can
emerge and a mod that doesn't have
anything human right there's nothing
human about Transformers but they're
just very good at things and and and you
know we we think that whales are pretty
good at some aspects as well so we might
be on the lookout for these cases and
then the last thing I'll be I'll be
finished very soon but the last thing is
um and I don't have much to say here but
just like a real hope that
um we need to get into a acquisition
um and and we need to understand how
this is learned and how it's transmitted
from um and and how how developmental
stages work uh because because that's
going to give us really important cues
uh clues about uh you know kids learn
the simplest thing first they learn
syllable ma or ba
um and and as we're listening to them I
think we're going to be getting a lot of
Clues from from from the babies
okay so um I think a couple of tangible
results uh we have a framework that does
which properties are meaningful
which is basically combining
interpretability with generative models
and and we have a tangible result which
we shouldn't be throwing Acoustics away
um and and so so
um basically I think the main two ways
where generative models can help us is
to understand what is Meaningful and
that's what is Meaningful
um and then this the test what is
possible in non-human intelligence so
that we might be on the lookout for
various various properties
okay so a couple of the papers the QR
code will take you to the link with all
the papers and uh thank you for your
attention
on on using human languages that
benchmarks with this process be able to
spot properties that are not found in
human language but could be found in
World Language
yeah
it's as unbiased as I mean it's still
biased and still limited but it's as
unbiased as you could hope for
okay
I mean the question is will will be will
we be able to see it recognize it to to
make you know use these things exactly
to extract that information that's a
tougher part yeah
um
thanks thank you for the talk
um I I was wondering
um with with Gans you can generate novel
utterances or potentially you could
generate utterances that are designed to
closely approximate something that
actually exists in the Wales
Communication System but maybe produce
like a different version of of the same
thing like you know of the same word in
a different speaker's Voice or something
like that but I guess with with human
language we have the advantage of being
able to say that the output of a gan
sounds right or doesn't but with the
whales we don't have that option so
um what what do you think we can do to
overcome that obstacle yeah yeah if we
want to like do playbacks in the future
for example like how would you
um how would you design uh how you
design the model to generate
um whale vocalizations that
that are meaningful without you know
knowing what is Meaningful so this
actually uh relates to the question
producer I asked right uh the way the
methodology works is we're testing for
what it
considered like what it is designed to
encode
from this interaction with the data via
the discriminator right so that's like
one check and uh I don't know if you're
extremely obvious from the plots we were
actually wearing the coding right so
along that variation each point
represents like thousands of examples
right so none not all of those who are
superiors right so it's uh more of a
question I guess than
uh you decided to encode this and using
this rule it generates new stuff right
and the fact that it uses this rule to
generate stuff that's not seen is the
answer itself
uh I don't know well I guess the
question is like I'm thinking in terms
of potentially doing a playback
experiment
um if if you want to do a playback
experiment with whales you have to know
not just that this is something that is
probably meaningful to whales but you
have to know what it means so if you
have a model that say I don't know like
let's say you figure out that this
particular call means
um let's dive now right
um just as a simplistic example and then
you want to generate uh a version of
that call in the voice of of a different
whale saying let's dive now you have to
know not only that it's a possible call
in the whales language you have to know
that it means that specific thing
but we don't have external meaning yet
so this is all internal meaning but um
but the fact that one one I think one
reassuring fact is also yes gas can
always be you know can always be good
you can always get over generate but one
reassuring fact is that we found two
things that are you know human style
very meaningful
um are very prominent same code at me as
meaningful as well there as well but so
so this is none of this is yet
um you know external meaning foreign
peers that we don't have that yet right
you know I'm just thinking more like as
the next thing but we you need to know
what what to look for in the next step
right that's that's hypothesis shrinking
part right because
um because it's gonna make our life much
easier if we know that Acoustics should
not be a thrown away for example because
right and stuff like that right so uh
but yeah there is no external meaning
yeah just like there is no external
meaning in words but but words have
meaning right so it's possible that the
things that the rails are learning I
actually you know has external it's
probably even likely that it has
external meaning we just didn't make
that connection right let's see how we
would do it without testing on the
website because they're the only uh
animals that actually know what anything
means yeah of course but but the
challenge is you can't just do infinite
playbacks yeah so that's that's the
biggest challenge that we so we were
able to go get around the problem of
experimentation here just to decode
decompose like uh building blocks of
communication because we could simulate
it by a gun experiment right but
unfortunately I don't think we have
training data to be able to train a
simulator which would we would input our
reconstructed utterance from these
building blocks and the general will be
Faithfully uh use back what the well
would do because that's almost
impossible to do right yeah
all right thank you
um really appreciate that so we're now
going to break for an hour and 25
minutes for lunch
and um yesterday Shafi brought us to the
to the law school which is just nearby
so lunch is on your own
um and we'll see you back here at uh 2
30.
foreign